la fédération française de cyclisme a
réussi son pari les championnats de
france cadets juniors et masters sont pu
se tenir ce dimanche 21 février sur
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
malgré le contexte sanitaire et
l'annulation de la plupart des courses
en france
quand on a compris qu'on ne pourrait pas
le faire tenir en même temps que le
championnat de france élite qui était
tout début janvier à pontchâteau et on
avait pris l'engagement de vraiment tout
faire pour essayer d'organiser un
championnat c'est avec beaucoup de
bonheur qu'on a reçu l'autorisation de
la préfecture il ya huit jours pour
pouvoir tenir effectivement ce
championnat l'événement s'est tenu à
huis clos avec un protocole sanitaire
une jauge maximale de 500 personnes en
simultané était également mise en place
des règles strictes qui n'ont pas
contrarié les 550 coureurs venus des
quatre coins de la france
les cyclistes présents n'ont pas boudé
leur plaisir de recourir après cette
saison de cyclo-cross bouleversé dossier
parfait un cross de la saison donc parce
que ça a été compliqué c'est vrai que là
ça va être la seule de savate la seule
c'est la seule compétition pour
l'instant à laquelle on a eu droit donc
c'était un objectif c'est un objectif de
l'année ça a été annulée reportée donc
bah voilà on est au rendez vous ce que
je garderai c'est simplement quand les
jeunes hier passer à côté de moi le long
de la ligne
non simplement le fait de dire merci et
sourire on avait déjà gagnés dans ce
week-end sur le plan sportif c'est 550
courant du se dépasser pour atteindre
leur objectif une boucle de 2 7 km
autour du centre équestre de l'île de
loisirs avait été imaginé il apporte
vraiment tout ce qui est le dans cette
discipline vous avez de la technique
vous avez des parties roulantes
vous allez partout il faut de la force
de vous connaître la trajectoire
il y avait des parties où il faut porter
le vélo ici on surligne olajire de 50
ans on est vraiment sur le territoire du
cyclo cross
vu le succès rencontré par cet événement
malgré la crise sanitaire les
organisateurs espèrent désormais
organiser un championnat de france élite
de cyclo cross à l'horizon 2024